i have something really interesting for
you today
asa hutchinson is the republican
governor of arkansas
he's a 70 year old white lifelong
conservative dude right he's not the
picture of progressivism
but there is one area in which asa
hutchinson's
traditional conservatism overlaps
with progressive social ideas and it's
on small
l libertarianism okay the progressive
view being
let people do what they want and be who
they
are without interference from the
government particularly
when they are issues where we talk to
medical experts we don't need
people like asa hutchinson telling us
what to do overlapping with the
conservative view
which is government should only be
involved
in anything when there's really a
specific reason
for government involvement it's not
government should take a position on
everything
it's we shouldn't even be involved in a
lot of things unless there's a really
good reason to do so
government doesn't have to have a say in
everything that's exactly the reasoning
for why republican governor
asa hutchinson vetoed a bill from the
arkansas house and senate
which would ban gender affirming
treatments for transgender minors
in the state of arkansas now
unfortunately asa hutchinson's veto was
overridden by the state house and senate
but hutchinson has made his view clear
the bill is too extreme
and the new law will have devastating
repercussions for transgender youth who
are
already undergoing various medical
treatments
in passing the save adolescence from
experimentation act this is what they're
calling it
arkansas became the first state to pass
a bill
restricting access to gender affirming
health care for anyone under 18
even with parental consent other states
have similar bills working their way
through
legislatures so hutchinson goes on
tucker carlson's show last night
it's actually fascinating to watch
because the governor explains
how his conservatism is what led him to
veto
the bill and tucker just looks confused
he does this confused face he seems
unable to understand it or unwilling
and at first tucker won't even let the
governor answer the question take a look
there's in the most sensitive issues and
so
why are we regulating the behavior of
children at all if we're allowing
children to decide and by the way
i read a study today that showed the
overwhelming majority of kids
who do not take life-altering hormones
in the end decide not to quote
transition to a new sex
so there's a lot going on here but i'm
asking as
a conservative you just incited invoked
ronald reagan as if he were for chemical
castration of children
what other behavior should we not use
the power of the state to regulate among
kids
seriously well you debate it every time
look tucker you want to keep talking you
want me to answer a question
sincerely thank you
and so whenever you whether it's it's
beer for minors these are all
issues that you have to address the
legislature you make judgment calls on
it
but we also try to restrain ourselves as
conservatives and say we don't have to
be involved in every issue
and if you want to broaden the party if
you want to get back to the principles
then
let's at least think through in a
reasoned way
as to whether this is the right bill to
interfere
with parents and doctors decisions on a
health care matter
as you pointed out has does not have
thorough research in every area
this is an actual conservative principle
we don't need to be involved in every
issue
now i am not praising this because
i would agree with him about every issue
in which the government should or should
not be involved but the republican party
has abandoned this supposed value
anti-wokeness owning the libs guns on
the house floor
none of this stuff is real traditional
conservatism as it used to exist
recognizing that they don't have to be
involved in every issue
even if they don't like what some people
are doing
that is a conservative value let's
continue
and so i yield to that whatever you look
at this bill
it might yield to the lack of research
really quick 10 years ago if somebody
had said hey ace hutchinson you're gonna
be governor of arkansas
and you're gonna veto a bill that would
have protected children from chemical
castration
what do you think you would have said
well just like i said today if you're
talking about
a reassignment surgery i would have
signed that bill in a minute
but whenever you're talking about maybe
less than 200 kids in arkansas that's
currently on
hormone treatment and they are
immediately cut off
without having a grandfather clause in
this legislation i don't think that's
treating those kids or their parents or
their
health care providers fairly or equally
all right that's the conservative
position governor thanks i appreciate
coming on
tucker here is ridiculing the idea that
this is a conservative position
that asa hutchinson is uh espousing
but it is hutchinson says the science is
unclear on some of this
that's absolutely true it is without a
doubt true that the science is not yet
clear
about the benefits and risks of
adolescent um
uh transitions that maybe wither without
medication
with or without surgery it's undeniable
i'm not even taking a position on that
it is still early in that process of
figuring out
what is good and what is not so good for
different people
but if that's the case you don't say
well then government decides
that would be more reason to say let's
leave this in the medical science
community even though it's still being
researched
medical science knows more than asa
hutchinson
that's the important principle here
and if it's as unclear as asa hutchinson
says
and it's still something being
investigated
why would politicians decide instead of
doctors it makes no sense
it is the conservative position and
unless there's a really good reason
and a body of evidence for politicians
to get involved
just stay the hell out of it and that is
exactly what asa hutchinson is saying
it's an actual conservative position and
tucker's
confusion about it or maybe feigned
confusion that's really anger
confirms to us once again that tucker
carlson's faux populism
there's nothing conservative about it
fundamentally nicely done
by asa hutchinson and um as far
as you know when as far as the science
as far as what should or shouldn't be
legal or at what age or with or without
parental consent
these are things that the medical
community
uh will figure out and is researching we
don't need
imagine the what is conservative about
thinking that you need the arkansas
state legislature and state senate
involved
in something with which medical science
is now
exploring and researching it's
delusional
and it's certainly not conservative let
me know your thoughts
we'll take a quick break and be right
back i'm really excited that
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
i sleep on a helix mattress at home i
absolutely love it and that's why i
reached out to them
about sponsoring the david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like
but helix has a sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position
your back pain issues you might have and
their
tool matched me with a mattress that is
perfect for me
it's cool enough at night it's the right
firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded
number one best overall mattress for the
last two years
by both gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you firsthand
every helix mattress comes with a 10
year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights
and they will even come pick it up at
your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium
pillows for free when you go to the link
right underneath this video